schooldays mo better blues king of New
York Malcolm X the usual suspects and
then in the smaller screen Breaking Bad
and now on better call Saul and in
theaters near you this very weekend
reprising his role in The Maze Runner
trilogy Maze Runner the death cure
starring in part gen Carlo Esposito good
to see you sir great to see you
I tell here what I told you
backstage big fan for quite some time so
I'm really appreciative of you being
here and then when I find out that you
and I share a love of the New York
Yankees of pinstripes oh my goodness
take me back to my child that's it
pretty much that your team that's my
team that's my team since the age of
probably about eight years old I went to
the older Yankee the great Yankee State
Yankees leather theater but a theater
great ballpark really great boy where'd
you normally sit in the stands
I normally sat you know somewhere right
behind home plate or off to the right
went with a dear friend Alan McMillan
who was a friend of my mom's a press guy
could never afford a ticket he always
bought us on Club day or bad day always
to came away with something sure which
was you know so wonderful yeah they used
to have bad day all the time and Yankee
Stadium until they realized they were
giving out bats to people yes and if the
Red Sox were there you'd have like a
little little bat fight suddenly they
became like mini bat day that's not they
used to give out like real reason
lumbermen as they did yes they did way
back when when I was a kid they didn't
it was always great to get those yeah
and I loved wooden bats and it makes me
think a lot about a couple of things one
you know back in my day we had Thurman
Munson as a catcher for the Yankees who
to me he's the reason why I became a
catcher in Little League because I loved
his aggressiveness his arm I love the
fact that he could hit the captain he
was the captain he was the man the man
and I makes me also think about a guy I
know who 25 years ago Joe Cosentino
started the Vermont Mountaineers okay
stovetop dinner and what they do is he
started baseball leagues for kids so I
honor his memory he passed away last
Friday and they do a dinner every year
and
they give away bats to young people
wooden bats so they can start to feel
how that wooden bat bat might feel in
their league and most of these young
people who were in this league go on to
the majors no kidding yep yep Joe was a
great man and 25 years ago March 24th he
started these leagues all across the
country and young people are still
benefiting from his gracious and
wonderful spirit no kidding yeah that's
neat I'm glad did you pay tribute to him
so what type of catcher were you John
Carlos oh man that was a good catcher
you know you know I knew you know I
caught a guy between third and home base
and we're throwing the ball back and
forth and I see he's gonna charge me so
I chucked the ball to the third baseman
and I just give him a nod when to get it
back to me he gets it back to me and I
just gutted him and my mother says I
don't have to do that I said well I had
the stomach was a good place right so
she said you're a good catcher so that's
it nothing got by me now I'm this day
and age that might be illegal you're not
allowed to making out a lot of block the
plate like you used to back in the day
now dad no that's the truth you know the
game has changed a bit unfortunately but
yeah we have to be careful but back then
as a kid I was very sure have you uh
have you been in the new Yankee Stadium
have you buy hats in there yeah and I've
enjoyed being there it's a different
feeling
it feels richer it feels more corporate
and I have a daughter who I've passed on
my love for the Yankees to Shane
Esposito she's 21 and when I go with her
I sit in the bleachers in the cheap
seats because that's what she's used to
she feels like we're family they're
different kind of folks sit there and
and you get a better view of the whole
stadium so I enjoy going with the cheap
seats it's pretty cool well this year
though and I think you'll even admit
this mr. Red Sox fan over there that in
the playoffs this year the new Yankee
Stadium captured a little bit of the old
raucous Yankee Stadium and Coliseum was
okay even with the way that at the top
of the stadium was right okay yeah so
the one time a couple times that I've
been to Rome and I've seen the old Roman
Colosseum first time I saw it I'm like
that looks a little bit familiar to me
and I'm like okay obviously Yankee
Stadium took it from the Romans but this
this year did feel it did feel like a
little bit of the old-school cauldron of
Yankee fans that there with this this
playoff run that nobody was expecting
this year with judge and the rest of
that very very exciting young people on
the team really excited to be getting
junk got a little Staunton coming to the
team an incredible athlete I mean look
we have a very rich team and other teams
are jealous I love the scrappy Red Sox I
have dear friends in Boston and that is
what we focus on
I'll go see one game at Fenway with them
okay and I'll wear my Yankee hat and get
yelled at and screamed at and they'll
come and see one game at Yankee Stadium
with me my friend Frank Mulaney and
he'll wear his Red Sox a hat he'll get
screamed at and debouch we do that every
year because it's a fun game that we by
the way I love the way you said
Stanton's first name obviously you have
some experience in that first name but
that's I can't believe they got him I
still can't believe the Yankees got him
I'm a bit shocked as well I am but
you're not a part of the belief that
Jeter handed him because he's he's The
Manchurian Candidate front office man
for the Miami Marlins he's trying to
just help the whole program I think
there is something to be said about man
let's take a break we're back in 60
seconds we'll talk Maze Runner which is
immensely popular and then obviously I
do want to go down to Breaking Bad
wormhole with you that's one of my that
to me it is the greatest I get
over-the-air if you will drama where you
do still have some constraints that you
wouldn't have if you were on pay cable
that's right it truly is one of the
greatest shows of all time and certainly
is under the constructs in which it was
created
I want to talk about that with Giancarlo
Esposito when we come back here in the
Rich Eisen show
[Music]
welcome back to our show Maze Runner the
death cure in theaters near you starting
on this Friday the man who plays the
role of Jorge Giancarlo Esposito here on
the show I wanted to start with your
your career first what did you first
hook it with Spike Lee how did that
happen I was doing a play calls new man
on the sign Negro Ensemble Company
1979-80 and Spike came to see it came
right backstage said I want to work with
you no kidding no right away he was
cleaning films at Maxie Cohen's place
just cleaning the films as they went
through the steam back and we started
talking about a film that was a musical
called school daze and he let me read it
and I said hey it's really great it's a
lot in here for a musical can you pull
it off and and and we did and my
relationship with him continued for
years and years because I respected what
he was trying to do I think he's a
wonderful filmmaker and he brings some
consciousness and some heightened
characterizations yes who was movies
where was the last time you saw do the
right thing
Wow I saw it three months ago no kidding
in the Netherlands a really horrible
copy but the film was great it's a bit
scratched but it was great how do you
feel it's hold held up I think it's held
up very well I think it really is a film
that has stood the test of time we're
still very much in some kind of
consciousness that this film should be
seen when my 21 year old daughter saw it
in her film class at 17 I'd never seen
any of my work she started to get what
New York was like then she'd never seen
any of your work she hasn't seen
anything you know she came and saw one
episode of Breaking Bad was episode 401
box-cutter
and I turned to her and I said just
remember that guy up there's Gustavo and
this is your father just realize that
she said okay Papa she watches the
episode she turns to me and she says
good kill Papa that's my girl that's my
girl that was the first episode she ever
saw she didn't like the show she didn't
get it and then she went back after that
episode watched it from the beginning
and went oh my goodness now I see I said
I told you
all my social medias yes that's how
excited she is well it's funny cuz I I
watch Breaking Bad from the very first
episode when it aired on AMC because I
was a Cranston fan and it just there was
something unique about the story as I
saw the commercials for it I'm like okay
I'm gonna give this a try
and I was hooked from the first minute
and my wife saw it and was just
disturbed she was disturbed by it and
then so I went through watching it
essentially by myself and then in the
last season as things were beginning to
cook for the lack of a better phrase in
a certain way I just I just said ah you
have to just trust me on this one
and then she binge I believe all 66 67
episodes of it in a span of about two
weeks Wow and I got to watch it again
and the amount of breadcrumbs that that
were dropped that's right
years before that's right things came to
be it's unbeliev it's layered shows i've
ever since the brilliance of vince
gilligan his writing team he takes
suggestions he works as a team player
but he has ideas and we all love great
novels where little seeds are dropped
and then all comes together and falls
apart by the middle of but it all comes
back together at the end this is a show
that's very similar to that it keeps
your mind fresh and it keeps you
thinking and trying to figure it out but
then it's different than what you could
have ever imagined part of the reason I
did this show is because during this
period of time when they asked me to
come and do a guest spot there was
there's this the whole beginning of the
scourge of crystal meth in America was
happening and you had we I read a story
about two young guys Mormon guys from
obviously Utah who did their mission and
disappeared and they wound up being
found months later selling using crystal
meth and I thought this is powerful and
awareness has to be brought to this
subject so yes so I decided to play a
drug kingpin to bring some awareness to
this subject through this show it was
one of the commitments that I made to
myself that people need to know about
this so we can become more savvy about
what our kids might be experimenting
under the cloak of an individual who
appears to be a first-rate community
responsible individual for sorry it
really is just a particularly dark
character that you play on the show what
do you think you personally brought to
it then because I'm imagining you gave
your own spin to Gus fring what did you
what did you bring to the table that
Vince Gilligan him the crew were like
okay stick with that well I finished
that first episode before I got off the
plane as the door was opening my phone
was ringing would you come back and do
another I was convinced I didn't want to
see the stereotypical bad guy do you
want to see the mafioso I am Italian
I've been to Italy with a little dog the
guy who's no I wanted to be a guy who
was affable part of the community who
handled his business like a business and
that people could eventually possibly
begin to like it was the calm demeanor
that I bought to this character that I
feel like really allowed him to be
elevated it was my yoga breathing it was
my attention on someone else
it was my caring about people Gus does
care about people he's brutal to them if
they don't do what he says but he's very
kind to them if they do he is the
ultimate father in the laundry business
in the drug business and in the chicken
business forget I make good chicken ala
for those poorest hermanos men and no
question about it but you're also the
magical company which by the way when
you saw the commercial for los loros
hermanos at the very bottom and the in
the fine print it said a magical
corporation at the very bottom that's
what I picked up on seeing that that
episode of second time and just to
continue just a couple more on this so
we stood I think it's Madrigal Madrigal
right what I said did I say something so
magical I like magical but I think it's
magical yeah and we're gonna get into
some more of that as we go back and
better call Saul well that's what I want
to get into as well one one question on
the demise spoiler alert now were you
disturbed by how you looked in that
final scene cuz I sure was I mean I
honestly dreamt about it how how it look
I didn't I can only imagine you you're
that's you on the screen it is me
extremely disturbing Vince checked in
with me we talked about it I said I
didn't want this death
to veer off into sci-fi land it had to
be real it had we had to believe it and
we agreed on that
yes very disturbing because I you know
was a four-and-a-half-hour make up a
trip to Los Angeles KNN you know Howard
burger actually did the work and I have
to say that too
I sat for a bust for an hour and a half
my lovely Shane Lyra came with me
very scary had to hold my hand couldn't
hear couldn't see and a lot of people
tap out they got to take it off so they
made that bus they did some digital
stuff afterwards and then on the day
they had to do all that make up and when
I finally turn I insisted on not being
looking in the mirror when it was being
done I turned my back and so they could
turn me around and I was in shock at the
artistry with which this was applied to
my face and I was in shock at how people
immediately started taking selfies of me
but it was a little bit creepy very very
creepy and so we had discussed a lot of
it Ethan says what might you be doing if
this happened and I said well look you
know Gus is very proper I closed my
jacket you know when I stand up I open
it when I sit down I said I would be
straightening mine and Vince just his
eyes lit up good for you and he said oh
my goodness what am I said yeah he's
preparing to go sold he's going to the
afterlife and then in better call Saul
can you are you in you're shooting it
now are you shooting this we're shooting
currently our fourth season we started
January 8th okay so we're in our cannot
wait for the connective tissue the
connective tissue is coming I'm really
excited I joined the cast on the third
season last year it's been a very slow
burn yes I'm enjoying people trying to
figure out what's gonna happen but now
hands on baby
really it's all down to burnt okay yeah
in a Gus way you know in a very gothic
does--is stealth I think they're really
quite amazed how I've come back to the
show
because I had to make a decision do I
gain weight to make him a younger Gus
because I'm younger many years younger
or do I lose some and make him even more
stealth and a little less polished and a
little more trying to find his power and
I decided to to lose some and when you
see what this guy does with his own
hands and how fast he does it's like
you know it's I met a guy once in
Detroit on the street he tried to rob me
he came up to me with a knife this is
how I think about this guy a lot because
I think about Gus and I looked him in
the eye and he was very frightening he
said I will cut your heart out and hand
it to you before you fall and as he said
those words I realized he meant it and I
said I have two choices here I can turn
and run or I can confront I had already
offered him money but the guy was high
as you would not believe and as he
finished saying before you hit the
ground
I had his knife I had his knife I had
shoved them and I says what do you want
now you want to keep coming or you want
to back off and he backed off that's how
fast gust is sometimes we have to react
very quickly this is going back many
years ago but I think of it because that
kind of physical emotional mental
connection is what it takes to do what I
do was Gus well and takes it what you do
is an actor Giancarlo Esposito here and
Plus you know hearing that makes you the
perfect badass for maze runner so I love
this movie this is this is intense it is
a big film for the trilogy and also I
mean there's a rabid fan base for this
too I mean you've been in two things
every monster rabid fan bases what's it
been like for you with with Maze Runner
you know I've loved it I love this
character of Jorge he has fun he's smart
he's erudite he's a reader he's an
explosive expert I love that he's the
only adult with the young people that he
has to learn to trust them I love that
when Thomas starts to say what his plan
is Gus questions him but then allows him
to say everything he has to say like we
have to do with our teenagers right you
know 16 19 you listen to them you learn
from them and that that you know Jorge
listens and goes okay I'm with you you
know this this particular film I respect
the director so much and I love the
studio who's producing this movie
they're onto something it's about family
it's films about family it's about not
leaving a man behind it's about saving
the world from the monopolies that have
taken it over it's about truth and
hopefully we'll never get to this
dystopian sure
that's described in the film but look
this movie is a long film that is
action-packed from beginning to end but
you still get character and you still
get heart and that's what I love about
it yeah and for the radio audience we
showed the first scene or the first
minute of the first scene and I was
sucked in right off the bat just awesome
yes yeah and you said the special
effects were done on a computer well you
know what kind of guy he marks
everything out on a computer he
describes it he then puts it on his
computer so that he can then relay it to
the the great effects teams and I find
him to be brilliant not only with what
he does in that arena but also how he
coaches us actors and-and-and for the
rabid fan base of Maze Runner what do
you tell the fans about us third film
not about non-stop action go see it it's
satisfying and that ultimately is what
it has to be you've had two other films
that cover the same Gladers and the same
characters you get to know them the fans
have been waiting so long to see this
third installment and it it really lives
up to all of its expectations does it
leave any unopened questions do you
think well you know I think more I think
it does leave some on open questions
because there are six novels you never
know James Dashner did a great job
writing six books we're at our third so
it leaves some questions I would love to
know how things turn out if we ever
really do make it to the safe haven and
if that is a place that is sustainable
right because if our world were to
become as crazy as the world in which we
live in the film then we're gonna have a
lot of scavengers trying to take it over
and find power but level heads will sort
of can change the game and I like this
film it gives our young people an
opportunity to see and get in touch with
their own humanity and their own power
so many young people between 13 and 19
years old and even 20 are afraid to say
what you want I tell my young people my
kids it's ask for what you want of the
universe in general think it ask it you
know that's the way to get it and ask
yourself a lot of questions about what
you want your life to be that's why I
still love doing what I do with this age
and you're all
I'm a tit man thank you you're awesome
at it and clearly you told Aaron judge
the same thing because look at him now
that's a big boy it is 2018 s good for
you man
yet the Yankees Maze Runner and better
call Saul thanks for coming on my place
helped this first of many times big fans
hope so too you've got Giancarlo
Esposito to Joy thank you on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience